over in brazil local governors there are
demanding that the country's health
authority
think again after it failed to approve
russia's sputnik v
jab they claim the decision wasn't based
on objective grounds
we studied sputnikv and realized that it
is one of the most
effective vaccines available with an
efficiency of more than 90
and without any significant side effects
this was one of the main reasons why our
state and 17
others out of 27 brazilian states signed
preliminary contracts for vaccine
delivery
and we all want to resolve the issue
with the reluctance of an visa
to allow the vaccine to be used in the
country
myself and other governors who requested
permission to import the vaccine
hoped for a positive decision by this
organization
brazil is now at a critical point of the
pandemic
we have reached 400 000 deaths and we
expect it on visa to show
objectivity we have already bought
37 million doses and we are waiting for
the decision
in order to distribute the vaccine
our main task at the moment is to ensure
the implementation of the law
which was recently adopted by the
brazilian parliament this law
specifically recognizes 16 national
regulators of other countries
including russia as valid on the
territory of brazil so the correct
action of an visa
would be to validate the decision that
has already taken place in russia the
approval of
the sputnik vaccine but the regulator
hasn't done this
but approach the issue as if it were a
completely foreign laboratory and it is
necessary to reproduce the entire
process here
unfortunately that's what's happened and
the process has been prolonged
yeah well let me tell you more detail
last week brazil's regulator said it
wasn't
confident in the jab safety sighting
among other things production flaws
it also claimed that one of the
components of sputnik v might pose a
risk to people with
weaker immune systems well didn't take
long for the vaccines developer as you
would expect to hit back
angrily calling the decision to hold
back on approval entirely
political and having nothing to do with
science
the gamalia center says its cleaning and
filtration system ensures the job is
highly purified with existing quality
controls
guaranteeing that no harmful components
exist in sputnik v
it also claims as well as you can see
there that it's almost 98 percent
effective very good brazilian governor
wellington diaz
told us more says it may be possible to
use
legal means now to try to force through
the russian vaccine's approval
how long this bureaucratic process has
dragged on as a matter of big concern
actually at the level of the brazilian
states there are at least two plans
the first is to ask the russian
manufacturer the gamale institute
the russian direct investment fund the
russian ministry of health
as well as other countries such as
argentina mexico and others
that already have experience using this
vaccine to provide an visa
the brazilian regulator with complete
information
so that they can finally give permission
and the second way is the supreme court
where there is also a possibility to
legally oblige and visa to accept the
russian vaccine
since we are talking about the fact that
this vaccine has been approved by
regulators in many countries
at least three other vaccines are
officially approved in brazil so if it
does not work out with and visa
then this path through the supreme court
is the one
we will follow